تحدث إلينا حول المشكلات المتعلقة
بالبنادق الدعائية ، وكيف يعملون ،
وكيف يفترض
أن يظلوا آمنين صباح الخير.
توخي الحذر الشديد مع أي نوع من الأسلحة سواء
كانت بنادق ذات دعامة مطاطية أو
بنادق وميض
وأي شيء بينهما ،
سنقوم عادةً
بعمل موجز للسلامة مع طاقم
الصب وسنقدم السلاح إلى فريق التمثيل
وسنتركهم يفحصونه.
سنشرح احتياطات السلامة التي تتماشى
مع كل نوع من أنواع الأسلحة الداعمة في هذه
الحالة ، فقد كان سلاح إطلاق نار فارغ ،
ومع وجود مخاطر متأصلة
رأيناها مع إطلاق برينان لي
منذ عدة سنوات ، فإن الأسلحة الداعمة
لها عامل خطير بالنسبة لها على
الرغم من  إنها أكثر أمانًا من استخدام
سلاح ناري حي على
حمل دعامة نموذجي ، سيكون حوالي 25 إلى 50 في
المائة من مسحوق البنادق في
حمولة مقذوفة فعلية يمكن استخدامها في
أي سلاح لاسلكي
مع ذلك في  ضع في اعتبارك أنه يجب أن تكون
هناك احتياطات أمان ، يجب أن تكون هناك
مسافات أمان ، وفي وقت ما كان هناك
حادث مؤسف ولم يتم اتباع تلك الأشياء التي
يمكن أن تخرج من مسدس فارغ إذا كان
من المفترض أن تحتوي البندقية المساندة على فراغات فقط ،
فكيف يكون هذا الشيء إذن؟
يمكن أن تخرج منه قذيفة في
أي وقت تتعامل فيه مع حمل قوة البندقية
وهو ما يوجد في سلاح الدعامة الذي
يطلق الفراغات
التي ستحصل على غاز ، ويمكن أن تحصل على
حرارة ، ويمكن أن يخرج منها الهواء
على الرغم من عدم وجود مادي فعلي
توجد مقذوفات مثبتة على الجزء الأمامي من هذا
السلاح
على الخرطوشة ،
وهي مقذوفات
تخرج مسحوق الغاز
ويمكن أن تتسبب في إصابات جسدية في
نطاق 25 إلى 50 قدمًا اعتمادًا على
الحمل في
نطاق 25 إلى 50 قدمًا وهذا في الواقع
بعض المسافة إذا كنت تفكر في  فيلم يحدد
كيف يمكن أن يكون الأشخاص المقربون خلف
الكاميرا
صحيحًا للغاية ولهذا السبب
نتوخى الحذر الشديد عندما نستخدم
الفراغات في المجموعة ،
ونقوم بعمل مسافات أمان نحاول
إبقاء الممثلين غير متوازنين قليلاً مع
السلاح  n
بحيث إذا أطلق الشخص النار على الأسلحة
مباشرة بهذه الطريقة ، فإن الممثل الآخر
في الإطار يكون بعيدًا قليلاً